I am a software developer who have been
using python for other web development
tool or data processing tool especially
for data science machine learning and
computer vision fields and I also have
been active in several osis projects or
some communities including streamlits
that will be the core topic of this
today's talk and uh
in today's talk I would like to talk
about you know introduce SD Lite that is
webassembly Port of streamlit
by the way there have been several talks
about some similar topics like
webassembly or some python Frameworks
based on
webassemular pile died in this
conference so I believe that this is one
of the hottest Topic in recent years
especially in of course in this
conference but also you know worldwide
python community
and before we will take a closer look
into SD like itself let me introduce
streamlit first in short and discuss
about its pros and cons
but first that will be also the
background of the birth of SD Lite
by the way
um how many of you have ever heard of or
heard about streamlit oh great thank you
that that's great and have you ever
heard uh have you ever used you're gonna
try that out
great so you're so there are many
funnels during it already but um let me
introduce about it in short as their
website of your website said it's a it's
a faster way to build and share data
apps
actually it's Unique and convenient way
to you know convenient feature that
makes web development super easy it has
become one of the most popular web
applications or dashboarding framework
written in Python and actually there are
many existing you know web-based demo
interesting applications ml use
showcasing some or some other any Autumn
things are existing in this you know are
also published in the world
and another thing about another great
things about streamlit is it's huge
active and welcoming Community where
many developers have been developing and
maintaining many custom components that
are kind of extension of stream leads
that cover wide range of but unique use
cases from something like you know
molecular biology or some media
processing application like this
although I only picked have picked up
two examples in this slide due to the
limitation of surface but you can find
some a great customer component from the
component list in the
offshore website linked from here
after explaining the nice things about
streamlit let me get back to this
introduction slide and focus on this
sentence saying stream listens data
scripts into shareable web apps in
minutes all input python no front-enders
no front-end experience required
so let's see what it means assume that
we we have a single python script named
app.pi written content like this
importing uh stream lead package here
and calling its functions like you know
ft.title here and in the next line is
still text input function is called and
its return value is assigned to the
variable name and uh this variable name
is also referred to you know used in the
next line the input argument to the SD
dot write function by the way in the
context of still a streamlit these
functions can be called as component
and uh them when we execute this command
extremely run command with an argument
pointing to the input file name app.pi
on the command line the streamlined
server side process will be launched and
it will start behaving as a web server
so that we can access the web
application from our web browser and we
can find that the content of this
application is based on what we have
written in the source code for example
here is a title component and here it
takes the input then text output
respectively and what's interesting and
unique here is that when user input some
takes data to takes the input element
and hit enter key the input Text data is
you know automatically reflected to the
text output field in the next line
automatically even though what we have
written in the source file is just a
simple
python script that has only you know
unidirectional execution flow simply top
to bottom whereas it does not have any
you know imperative or reactive Parts
like callbacks this is a you know magic
of stream list that converts such a
simple
um simple python script into interactive
web application of course it does not
require any front-end coding so due to
this you know convenient and unique
feature of streamlit it has been become
so popular especially for some type of
user groups like uh machine learning
practitioners or data science it's data
scientists imagine the more wide variety
of general purpose web developers of
course
because they have some awesome
achievement written in Python and they
want to create web application on top of
it but they do not want to pay so much
time or efforts to write front-end
coding
by the way uh let's see what happens
Under This Magic Magical conversion of
python code into interactive application
of course um when we run stream command
on command line on the server the python
runtime is loaded you know will be
launched and streamlit component will be
loaded onto it that has several
components including of course the
server and some static files like
index.html or main.js that will be
loaded soon and it also has contained a
dynamic part named script Runner that we
will we will see soon
but at first when we access to this web
server from our web browser the static
files like HTML or JS or css will be
served from the web server so that the
front-end application will be started on
the web browser
then
after the after the front-end
application we will be launched the
front-end app will establish the
bi-directional data connection with the
with the web server so that it will
communicate with the script run now so
that we never use a interact with a
front-end app like clicking buttons or
input inputting inputting text Data into
a text input field or whatever the
front-end app will send such input data
or input events to server side so that
the server side of the script Runner
will execute app.pi with such an input
events into data and the script Runner
will also send back the execution result
from app.pi to the server sorry
front-end application so that the
front-end app will re-render or update
the content of the front-end view this
is what they you know what's under the
hood of the magical
um generation of interactive publication
of streamlit
this is you know great you know great
but unique interesting architecture but
we also can see that this is kind of a
ordinary server client architecture
so that we can easily imagine that there
will be some type of drawbacks for
example you know it serves web pages or
web apps from web server and it also
runs the python script on the server
side to process the input data we cannot
use the hosted streamlined streamlit
application in offline environment of
course and whenever when we want to
process some data with hosted
Streamlight application the data must be
sent to the remote host
because of course you know the logic
implemented in Python is running on
there
so such so in that case there is no data
privacy but this could be sometimes to
be a problem conflicting with some um
business requirement or secret security
policy
and also from the Viewpoint of service
developers scalability is also sometimes
a big problem because streamlit
application means the dynamic python
runtime running on the server side
so here is SD light comes in
SD Lite is a port of streamlit to
webassembly with a with a concept of
client-side execution in other words SD
light is a fork of streamlits that runs
completely on web browsers
with the power of piodite that is a
python distribution for the browser and
node.js based on webassembly by the way
there was a great talk about pile diet
in this conference yesterday so please
watch that if you're interested in the
details about it
um by the way
um using piodite we could converted this
software client architecture of
streamlit into the serverless serverless
architecture of SD Lite you can find
that every Dynamic part written in
Python even streamlined package itself
including three scripts run now that
will execute app.pi are now running in
the web server precisely a web worker on
web browser so and the front-end
application is not communicating with
the server that is running on the client
side and the literally literally the
server now is a static file server that
will only distribute some initial static
files like index.html or some js or css
files
with you know serverless architecture
now we have solved some problems like
offline capability and data privacy or
scalability problems that we have seen
in the previous sections in addition to
them another benefit has been introduced
that is multi-platform portability that
we will see in the following slide soon
but at this point I think some of you
are thinking about other web of them
reported python Frameworks like you know
Jupiter live file script or something
like that so let me talk about them just
a bit
the
at first the history of webassembly
ported python Frameworks have been
started with Jupiter light or and its
bases piodite by the way there was a
great talk about Jupiter light
in the last year this conference so
please what's the recorded movie if
you're interested in although we do not
have enough time to go through all this
topic in the stock but anyway after
piodite has been released and this was
introduced to the python Community the
Big Bang has occurred you know Big Bang
of the client side python Frameworks
like including Pi script or shiny
gypptalli all over the panel and of
course SD Lite some are some are created
from scratch to be compatible with
browser environment and API like Pi
script and some are forked from existing
python Frameworks like SD Lite from
streamlit
actually there has been an active
discussion about
something like piodite depietal light
like streamlit in the official
streamlined online Forum so this is the
reason why I could start the development
of Steel light with the confidence that
there would be some kind of a needs for
the FD light that is you know Jupiter
light like streamlit in that sense the
development of the development of St
light has been hugely driven and
motivated by the community
right so until now I have been
explaining and reducing about some
Concepts and history of Steel light so
now it's time to show you some actual
demos
first thing I would like to show you is
this web
page or kind of web platform that is
named as FP Lite sharing
where um as you can see this is a web
platform where you know we can edit and
edit and preview streamlit applications
online in browser without any you know
explicit setup of python or installation
of streamlit package
and there are some several predefined
sample applications so let us see some
of them
late hello
demo is one of the most famous demo
applications of streaml is that we will
normally normally access this demo you
know when we use normal streamlit from
extremely hello command from the command
line but in the context of St Lite we
could see we could watch you know we
could see this demo on online without
installing installing a streamly package
itself and in this demo we can see that
some interesting or impressive features
of streamlit that streamlit provides by
default as the part of its unique
features like image frame generation for
animation or of course and chat is it a
plotting demo with some Charter chart
component and here is 3D map
application and here's you know kind of
a table data with data frame and some
Dynamic data filtering
again all these features are provided by
streamlit by default but the point here
the point here is that
if the lights are on FD like these
unique features are still available with
100 coverage
again on this component Gallery example
is also showcasing some availability of
extremely features on st-like
environment you know serverless
environment
that is that contains some you know all
the list of default
uh built-in component from the provided
by streamlit sorry it takes a bit time
to
build up
let me give all right
this is kind of a Showcase of the
various components available of
available in Streamlight environment
like various kind of or chat component
or some media components including oh
audio or and here is a map 2D map
component and this is a pi plot
and this is embedding demo invading
video demo and uh here's the table table
data and this it also provides various
kind of you know input components for
various types of input data like Boolean
value or
colors right
and as I said earlier custom components
are the one of the greatest parts of
streamlined community so this example
showcasing the availability of
custom component too in addition to the
default component of streamlit
let me give some time all right it can
it it includes some custom components
like this is the AC grid component this
is a graph for graph data
and this is more like a different types
of demo like image cropping for your for
multimedia applications and this is a 3D
molecule data visualizer
the next demo is kind of a bit different
but still interesting that is hosted on
GitHub pages
this is for you know demonstrating some
image processing feature on top of SD
Lite
the point here is that again everything
is working on client side because you
know GitHub pages is only for static
file serving so there is no server side
Dynamic python runtime please note it
again again and
let me give some time to all right in
this demo we can input some
image data from this local web camera
and we could also apply some image
manipulation to this image frame like
this like a
you know manifolding or some applying
some filter
and there's also some result of image
analysis is up output with matbot leave
the although this image filter or image
manipulation are kind of a trivial
examples but the point here is that
these features are provided by opencv so
the point here is that
or even opencv is running on client side
game the next example is a bit is
similar to the previous image processing
demo but the difference is that the
target domain is not still image but a
live video stream
let me see let me wait a bit
but the point uh the interesting point
is that these uh image processing is now
working at the client side and these you
know demos are
kind of interesting demo that's
showcasing the benefit of the
client-side execution of St light
because you know such kind of image or
video data are one typical type of
privacy sensitive data so this kind of
you know media processing demo running
on completely client-side is one you
know typical but uh imp you know
appealing demo that's showcasing the
the benefit of data privacy guarding of
the FD light
all right let's get back to the slide
and sorry okay
so at this point I'd like to introduce
some
Ways available ways to develop and
deploy St light applications
I mean now we are we can run streamlined
applications on webassembly so the
target domain Target platform is not
only web application web but also we can
package desktop or mobile apps the first
option is sdl sharing that we have in
the previous section but I would like to
show you here is that this link where we
can open up the dedicated View for the
application that does not contain a
editor view by clicking this link or
opening this URL in the new tab the one
interesting point here that every source
code and necessary data are encoded and
embedded into this URL string so you can
save save restore and share this entire
application just by copying and pasting
this URL string and note that that and
it also means that these data are never
stored on the server side
and we also have an option to self host
SD light application on our own website
by creating a simple a single index HTML
file and load JS and CSS files from C
for Ft Lite and embed some python code
at the string literal and past path that
string literal to St Lite API like this
this is the way I used to deploy this
you know opencv application demo in the
previous section
and we also have an option to package
the three minute application into
desktop executable file and FD Lite is
providing a dedicated way to do to
realize it that is named as SD Lite
desktop package that is distributed from
npm not that not that this is npm
package not Pi package and you can
create a desktop executable file based
on your streamlit source files just by
following this instruction on the readme
so if you please check it out if you're
interested in creating desktop app based
on streamlit and this is kind of a
experimental project but I recently
released a vs code extension that
realized in editor preview of streamlite
application one interesting application
of it is combine a combination of vs
gold web and this extension that
realizes the streamlite application
development even on iPad
all right sorry there was there is no
not enough time to go through all the
remaining slides but to be fair I have
to say that some there are some
differences between streamlity and SD
light
all of which are derived from the
difference between iodide and normal
python environment so please take care
of some some these things if you
actually try out development of
Streamlight application on St light I
will you know upload this slide to the
discourse so please read this slide if
you are interested in
sorry we are running out of the time but
at last my message is that now you're
ready to use this delight I hope and
thank you for listening to my talk and
uh thank you
thank you again for your great talk I
said earlier that you have a long way to
come to here perhaps the conference
attendees can just write where there are
from just use the hashtag picon de or
hashtag Pi data Berlin on social media
however let us just first talk about
some questions the listeners write down
on slido okay
first question how stable is St light
ready to production oh good question
well I
how should I say what should I say I
the version number is not still 1.1.0
but I think you can try out this
software for your
product near production ready
so you can try it out I think the
coverage of the pro available streamlit
features or some third-party custom
components near 100 with just a small
amount of exception of like a derivative
from the difference as I said between
the piodite and normal python
environment or something like that
how do you compare plotly Dash versus
streamlit
yeah that's exactly a big topic I
actually talked about this topic with
some developers from plotly yesterday in
the conference well
the big difference is uh is uh execution
flow extremely it's kind of a has a
um unique execution flow as I presented
in the previous slide like uh you know
from top to bottom single indirectional
execution flow and uh extremely script
will be executed every time when user
inject with the front end so I think
it's a
good thing for you know
like a small project a prototyping and
that is a great thing I really love it
but in some cases for example creating
some complex and uh high frequency
updated applications that such a
extremely tactic there could be a
drawback downside so in in such a huge
or complicated or performance sensitive
applications plotly might be the better
choice but yeah it depends on the target
domain or Target
you know software type
what was the decision behind introducing
a fork where this moving streamlit
itself to awesome what is the future of
streamlit in light of St light ah good
question but it was just a technical
limitation I there was no other choice I
just forked it to because
um some modifications onto the Upstream
stream extremely source code and
upstream was needed but um I am
you know the developer of SD Lite with
me is continuously contacting with the
Upstream developer on the core extremely
team to catch up their Upstream changes
into you know stream SD light package so
yeah I have a positive
hope to you know to make St light be
compatible in the near future
can you still perform requests against
remote services like a model or simula
so sorry
can you still perform requests against
remote services like a model or similar
oh yes yes uh that's exactly I wanted to
talk about in this slide
um
there were some limitations
um based on the pile that the
environment of browser environment but
there was
um
yes
for example in private URL leave or some
request does not work this is not
limitation due to SD light but this uh
this is due to the browser environmental
parody but still there are some
available methods to access remote
resources that are that is piled HTTP Pi
fetch or some some libraries wrapping it
so it's possible it's possible but
there's there will be some differences
May St lie to be an easy fronted
solution to a database for special use
cases of business users
I think so yes you know yeah it depends
on it depends on the situation but
like uh especially as I um
you know I I've heard some business
users are using SD live for their
internal uses especially for
data privacy or offline usage use cases
offline requirements so in the specific
case it's still like who's your best
choice that will communicate with some
data source in a private environment
but of course you can
we should be open for any other any
options that will be best for your
situation of course
could you utilize more advanced features
of opencv such as face detection or
facial gestural recognition
I think so
well actually in this demo included
fifth detection although it was based on
Psychic image not opencv but yeah thanks
to the huge contribution by the pilot
team opencv was ported to pile that the
environment and it I think it contains
such a advanced feature like
fix detection or something like that so
I think it works it will work
okay the time is up but because we have
a break next I think we can do the last
question I have here when packaging SD
code in an HTML app how feasible is it
to import not native packages and
external data
ah I see maybe this that this question
is based on the limitations of piodite
probably you know
such limitation is at the same as the
limitation of iodized so there's no
difference like uh native packages
compiled already compiled for pilot
environment like you know opencv XD
boost or something like that can be
imported as the light application but
other than not
unfortunately okay thank you for your
answers
I think he had a great talk even if it
was a little short out in the end
or to all of you have a great break
thank you